During 2020, when we've all been out of the office, we've been building a new one.
Or rather, we've been having one built for us. The new office is on the outskirts of
Nutsford, about a mile from the centre of town. We're at Booths Park, which is a beautiful
setting with over 200 acres of open parkland. It's a high-spec modern building tailor-made for us.
The materials and the design are all about blending in with our natural surroundings
and bringing the outside in.
We've got our own restaurant and fitness studio.
The building has been designed from the inside out to support the ways we work,
maximising our flexibility and our opportunities for team collaboration.
We're currently working on the internal fit-out and things are starting to take shape.
The new office should be finished later in 2021, around the time that hopefully we'll be able to
occupy it. We'll share another tour of the building a bit nearer the time.